we know everyone's finishing out October
with a stranger things binge but once
those final credits roll how will you
filled an upside-down shaped hole in
your heart with more TV of course
November is bringing plenty of new
movies and shows to get excited about
here's everything coming to Netflix in
November 2017 starting with the Netflix
originals alias grace season 1 Hulu may
have snagged The Handmaid's Tale but
Netflix is fighting back with alias
grace another drama series based on the
works of author Margaret Atwood grace is
the semi-biographical tale of grace
marks a girl who was convicted of
murdering two people in 1843 the Netflix
adaptation star Sarah Gadon is the title
character and will be released as a
six-part miniseries on November 3rd the
big family cooking showdown season 1 get
ready for a mouth-watering good time
with this unscripted cooking face-off
each episode of the big family cooking
showdown sees two families go
head-to-head to prepare the best dish in
a series of challenges netflix got
distribution rights for this popular BBC
two cooking show which originally aired
in the UK in August 2017 stream all of
season 1 and November 3rd fate Apocrypha
part 1 based on the series of light
novels of the same name
fate Apocrypha is an all-new anime
series that follows two warring clans
the red faction and the black faction at
the outbreak of an epic magical war
Netflix and a-1 pictures originally
aired the series exclusively in Japan in
July 2017 and they're bringing the
dueling mages stateside on November 7th
if you're an anime fan this is one new
series you can't miss the killer Netflix
is extending their international
acquisitions this month with the killer
a Brazilian crime thriller that looks
just as intense as its name would
suggest the story centers on a man named
shaggy who's on a one-gun mission to
track down a notorious outlaw Netflix
hasn't released many details about this
film but the killer looks like the
Portuguese spaghetti-western we've all
been waiting for and we didn't even know
it check it out when it hits Netflix on
November 10 blazing transfer students
season 1 if fate Apocrypha doesn't say
to your anime appetite
tune in to season one of blazing
transfer students while it's not anime
it's a live-action sequel to the manga
of the same name
blazing transfer students promises to
offer up plenty of anime style with a
premise so ridiculous we won't be able
to
not watch it seven boys I'll name Kakeru
get transferred to a new school at the
same time on a secret mission and see
that the worst or the best thing we've
ever heard and we'll find out for sure
when the series hits Netflix on November
10 lady dynamite season 2 there's always
something unexpected in each episode of
Netflix hit comedy lady dynamite and
fans can now look forward to a brand new
season Maria Bamford returns as well
herself to headline eight new episodes
alongside cast regular Fred Melamed both
Bamford and Netflix have remained
tight-lipped about what the new season
will entail
but if it's anything like season one we
can expect plenty of Banford signature
humor tune in on November 10th
DeRay Davis how to act black stand-up
comedian DeRay Davis lands on Netflix
this November with how to act black a
new comedy special pulled straight from
Davis's stand-up routines
according to Netflix the special will
dive into life and show business from
Davis's point of view promising a knock
out series of punchlines and anecdotes
that any comedy fan is sure to love take
a look on November 14th The Punisher
Season 1 from the minute he was
introduced in season 2 of daredevil fans
have been eagerly awaiting Frank castles
solo Netflix outing and the wait is
finally over Jon Bernthal returns as the
skull shirted antihero on November 17th
season 1 of The Punisher will be
comprised of 13 episodes and Daredevils
Deborah Ann Woll co-stars
although there's no hint whether
daredevil himself will make an
appearance or any of the other defenders
for that matter
Jim and Andy the great beyond in 1999's
man on the moon Jim Carrey turned in a
powerful performance as comedian Andy
Kaufman and as the documentary Jim and
Andy the great beyond reveals Carrie
went to insane lengths for the role
literally psychotic links the
documentaries composed mainly of
behind-the-scenes footage from the set
of man on the moon in character every
step of the way Carrie would torment the
director provoke his co-stars and
basically Kaufman the hell of the entire
production Universal didn't want the
footage she took behind the scenes to
surface so that people wouldn't think I
was in it even off the set Karia meshed
himself in Kaufman once spending two
hours in the phone with director Ron
Howard to talk about their upcoming film
How the Grinch Stole Christmas in
character as Andy
men it may have worked wonders for man
on the moon but at the same time it
probably explains just as much about the
mess that was the Grinch you can see the
craziness for yourself when Jim and Andy
debuts November 17 Longmire season 6
saddle up because Netflix critically
acclaimed crime drama Longmire is
galloping into its sixth and final
season on November 17th if we can
believe the trailer this looks like the
end of the road for series protagonist
Walt Longmire who's ready to turn in his
badge and give up his life as a lawman
Netflix grab this modern-day Western
when a Andy pulled the plug after three
seasons making this long Meyers third
season under the Netflix umbrella mud
bound this Netflix original centers on
two soldiers at the end of world war two
who returned home to rural Mississippi
only to find that in many ways their
struggles are just beginning mud bound
premiered at the Sundance Film Festival
in 2017 to critical acclaim and Netflix
picked it up for distribution sitting
tight with an exceptional percent rating
on Rotten Tomatoes mud bound definitely
looks like a film worth waiting for
check it out on November 17th Brian
Regan nunchucks and flamethrowers with
his sarcastic delivery and laid-back
comedic style Brian Regan has been
making audiences laugh for decades now
and he's back with a new stand-up
special coming exclusively to Netflix
nunchucks and flamethrowers promises
all-new jokes and more of Regan's
OnPoint commentary and everyday life
check it out on November 21st saving
capitalism this movie began life as a
Kickstarter campaign that ultimately
raised nearly three hundred thousand
dollars for the film's production the
documentary follows robert rice as he
travels the nation to speak to Americans
about the state of the country and how
people with different political views
can find a common ground saving
capitalism should offer an interesting
glimpse into the political climate of
the US look for it on Netflix at
November 21st
godless our westerns making their big
comeback it sure seems like it
and Netflix upcoming godless is the
latest outlaw joining the gang starring
Jeff Daniels godless tells the story of
Frank Griffin a bandit hell-bent on
getting revenge against his ex-partner
the six-part miniseries was created by
Scott Frank who penned Logan with Steven
Soderbergh serving as executive producer
get set for all the slick six-shooter
action on November 22nd she's got to
have it season 1
Spike Lee's 1986 romantic comedy she's
got a habit wasn't a smash hit by any
means but it brought in over seven
million dollars on a $175,000 budget so
you could definitely call it a financial
success and apparently the honchos and
Netflix thought it wouldn't be a
terrible idea to capitalize on that by
turning it into a series even if it
happened twenty-one years later the show
will follow the same premise as the film
one woman has three lovers but hesitates
to settle down with any of them will
they capture the same magic as Lee's
original film we'll all have the chance
to find out when season 1 premieres on
November 23rd Cuba and the camera man
after making waves at the Venice
International Film Festival Jon Alpert
Cuba and the cameraman is set to come
out on Netflix on November 24th the
documentary chronicles four decades of
revolution war and communism in Cuba
under the rule of Fidel Castro it's not
like viewing but Cuba and the cameraman
should go on everyone's list of must-see
documentaries frontier season 2 Jason
Momoa as gritty period dramas getting a
return with season 2 launching viewers
back into the blood-soaked action in
frontier justice created by Rob and
Peter Blacky frontier follows mow mow
his character Declan harp and his fight
against fur traders in eastern Canada
critics have given the show mixed
reviews with some praising the action
and the set pieces and others to writing
frontiers inconsistent pacing however if
you're looking for something
action-packed to watch while you kick
back and relax
you can catch frontier season 2 on
November 24th trailer park boys out of
the park USA in the first installment of
the Trailer Park Boys semi spin-off show
out of the park bubbles Julianne and
Ricky went to Europe to spread their
shenanigans abroad in the second season
they're heading to the States
some fans felt out of the park just
wasn't as good as the show so fingers
crossed the second season will bring
back that old trailer park magic holy
Moses seal don't scare me look for out
of the park USA and November 24th glitch
season 2 there been several different
series about people mysteriously coming
back to life in recent years from the
French labor of a nom to the American
remake the returned an ABCs unrelated
resurrection this idea somehow became
the most remade trope in recent memory
and the Australian telling of the story
lych is built on the same bones citizens
of a small town have to come to grips
with the fact that their loved ones are
returning from the grave but while the
American series fell a little flat which
was much better received and went on to
win several Australian Television Awards
Netflix came in to co-produced season 2
which airs internationally November 28th
Good Morning Call's season 2 based on a
manga of the same name
Good Morning Call's a romantic comedy
series about a girl who accidentally
becomes roommates with a hottest boy in
school
Japanese shenanigans ensue leading to
plenty of ridiculous situations and a
few unexpected friendships season 2 is
set to land on Netflix on November 28th
so keep your eyes peeled that covers all
the Netflix originals now let's take a
look at some of the new movies Netflix
is adding to its lineup in November new
movies to start with Netflix is adding a
handful of new action movies this month
on the first look for chappie a sci-fi
action comedy from district nines Neill
Blomkamp as well as men and black that's
what I'm talking about November 1st is
also seeing the addition of some classic
comedies like the original scary movie
and the whole nine yards for more
serious watch be sure to check out
brand-new documentaries like 2016's it's
not yet dark an inspiring story about an
Irish filmmaker Simon fitzmorris
who set out to direct a film after he
was diagnosed with neurodegenerative ALS
at the age of 34 look for it November
2nd other documentaries to watch for
this month include 27 teens Williams a
supercharged glimpse into the founder of
the Williams Formula One team and long
time running a music driven glimpse into
Canadian rock band The Tragically Hip
Netflix drama line-up is similarly
getting better in November with 42 Field
of Dreams Michael Clayton and the
pursuit of happiness all arriving in the
first of the month those are some
hard-hitting films but don't worry
Netflix is adding plenty of films for
family time too with Kasper and
Charlotte's Web hitting the service on
November 1st
scooby-doo two monsters unleashed on
November 13th and the boss baby on
November 22nd then once the kids are in
bed keep the post Halloween chills going
with Silent Hill and oculus on November
1st in 2017 s darkness rising in the
27th but horse shouldn't be too serious
you can also look forward to the campy
scares of 2010's piranha 3d on November
20th
new television if the first of the month
comes and you finish binging on stranger
things already don't
freak out there are plenty of other
shows to grab your undivided attention
in addition to the Punisher Netflix is
bringing on season 1 of stranger a South
Korean mystery thriller about a police
prosecutor on the hunt for a serial
killer the series garnered rave reviews
in its home country and you can
experience all the twists and turns on
November 1st also get ready for police
on convict action cop style with under
arrest season 7 dropping on the first of
the month and lockup state prisons
arriving on the 15th finally settle in
for the third season of broadchurch on
November 27 the critically acclaimed
British drama that was nominated for
seven BAFTA Awards in its first season
and which Entertainment Weekly went so
far as to call a bona fide national
obsession
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]